Hãy hôm qua vừa lần đầu công bố kế hoạch tập, máy định dành dân dân cho tình rô hình người,
nhằm quan lý tâm đồ vòng đời bệnh tế bệnh tử khi sớm đến khi người mà đau thông tin được lưu ra khi nên tàng dịch bố
của anh li vòng đời đầy đồ của của rô bó hình người, giảm mắt ngày hành tập nằm tại Buckingh.
Theo dưới trước chúng quốc, môi đô bốt trong tương lai sẽ xảy hữu một mặt sổ ruy nhất của Mb.
Đóng phải cho như thế cảnh tức, đô bốt, kể thông má hóa đu chia thành một phần, gồm mặt của ra,
má dân nghiệp sản xuất, má sản thẩm và số xe ri, dàng phục của truy xuất, mỗi góc sẽ xuất,
từ sản xuất, lưu thông cho tình đã chế, dưới trước chúng quốc cho biết việc trình và mặt định dành,
đô tụi đời trong bối cảnh ngày đồ bó hình người phát hiện nhánh chống.
Năm hành hình hái lòng, chúng quốc trên hơn chỉ mới phần chăm tổng đồ bó hình người, xuất sửa và gầu,
với nhiều răng nghiệp môi điện mọi rộng thương mại hoá và trên khai uống dụng trên quy môi lớn.
Tuy nhiên, sự phát hiện nhánh phúc làm giá tăng các vấn đề liên quan tế quan li, an ninh và trời gẹ phát li khi đồ bóng ngày cả xuất hiện nhiều trong gián xuất,
lưu sống và công dạc công góc, theo dõi chuyên gia, kể thông nghiệp giá thông nhất sẽ giúp tăng cả đặc kiểm soát,
truy xuất trời gẹp và hỗ trợ mọi giá phục rộng bó hình người trong tôn lài.